تعتمد الحلويات اللبنانيه على الاغلب من
مكونات طبيعيه وموجوده في اليابان على عكس
الحلويات الغربيه التي تعتمد على مجموعه
واسعه من المكونات من حول العالم تعتمد
يابان على بعض من ثمارها لصنع الحلوى
ابرزها الخوخ والبرقوق بدلا عن السكر كما
يعتبر الارز مكون مهم في عدد من الحلويات
اهم هاموتشي احد اهم ممثلين مطبخ الحلوى
الياباني مربى الفاصولياء انكو هي عجينه
تصنع من فصول الازوكي المسلوقه ومكون
اساسي من حشو العديد من الحلويات
اليابانيه والعشي من الحلويات التقليديه
الشهيره التي تدخل فصليه في تح وتتميز
بتصاميمها المختلفه في موسم الربيع مثلا
تاخذ شكل اشجار الكرز او ما يعرف باسم
ساكورا ويتم تقديمها مع الشاي
الشاي الماتشا الشهير ليس شرابا فقط بل
مكون شائع في الحلويات ايضا يستخدم في
تحضير الكعك والحلويات وهو ايضا نكهه ايس
كريم متداوله